thank you
the Earth trembling
tsunamis surging
hurricanes raging and volcanoes erupting
these Unstoppable forces leave
destruction in their wake
but what if we could control Nature's
most fearsome events
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we could control natural
disasters
first up let's talk hurricanes these
storms can cause a whole lot of damage
especially along coastlines
they release an astonishing amount of
energy equivalent to a 10 Megaton
nuclear bomb exploding every 20 minutes
that's just mind-blowing
hurricanes get their strength from warm
ocean waters
so if we could somehow cool down those
Waters we might be able to weaken the
storms or even stop them from forming
one idea is to use giant underwater
turbines to mix warm surface water with
cold water from deeper down
it sounds cool right
but there's a catch it would be a
massive project and we don't know how it
would affect the environment
plus we'd have to figure out where to
put all those turbines and how to
maintain them
[Music]
hey what if fans ready to Unleash Your
curiosity introducing the what if top
100 book a mind-blowing collection of
our most captivating questions and
answers dive into this beautifully
illustrated book and explore the
mysteries of our universe
from the depths of the ocean to the
edges of space discover the answers to
questions you've always wondered and
some you've never even thought of packed
with stunning visuals and fascinating
facts the what if top 100 book is the
perfect addition to your library or a
fantastic gift for the curious minds in
your life unlock your imagination with
the what if top 100 book available now
[Music]
it's quite surprising but around the
world there are about 500 000
earthquakes each year most of them are
small and go unnoticed but around 100
000 can be felt and about 100 of them
cause significant damage
Earth is constantly shaking earthquakes
are caused by the earth's tectonic
plates moving around and bumping into
each other we can't stop that from
happening but maybe we can find a way to
release stress along fault lines before
it builds up and causes a big quake
one idea is to inject fluids into the
ground to help the plates slide past
each other more easily it's a neat idea
but there's a risk we could actually
trigger more earthquakes by doing that
and we'd have to figure out what kind of
fluid to use and how much to inject
volcanoes are a whole different Beast
there are around 1 500 active volcanoes
on Earth today and in the last ten
thousand years alone we've seen about 1
300 to 1 500 confirmed eruptions
to stop an eruption we need to mess with
the volcanoes insides
picture this we drill into an active
volcano and remove some of the magma
which could lower the pressure and stop
an eruption from happening
it's a wild idea but it's also really
risky
drilling into a volcano is super
dangerous and we might just set off the
eruption we're trying to prevent
plus we'd have to figure out what to do
with all that magma we remove
thank you
alright let's talk about floods floods
are the most common natural disaster
worldwide they can happen anywhere due
to various factors like heavy rain or
rapid snowmelt
they can cause a ton of damage
especially in low-lying areas so what if
we could control where the water goes
and prevent it from flooding our homes
and cities
one idea is to build giant retractable
barriers that can be raised during a
flood to keep the water at Bay
we could also create better drainage
systems like bigger storm drains and
canals to move the water away from
populated areas
but as you might guess these projects
would be expensive and could have some
not so great impacts on the environment
like building those barriers might
require constructing huge dams which
could mess with the natural flow of
rivers and disrupt ecosystems
plus all the materials we've used to
build them could contribute to carbon
emissions and Destroy natural habitats
here's the thing if we could control
natural disasters we'd have some big
questions to answer
like who gets to decide when and how to
step in
and how do we know if we're helping or
hurting the environment
messing with nature might have some
unexpected results
we meet to think long and hard about the
consequences of our actions then make
sure we're not causing more harm than
good
and we'd have to figure out how to work
together as a global Community to make
these decisions
so what's next for controlling natural
disasters
researchers are working around the clock
to come up with new ideas and
Technologies
they're using satellites to monitor
weather patterns developing Advanced
Computer simulations to predict
disasters
and even working on creating materials
that can withstand extreme conditions
but until we can control natural
disasters we need to focus on getting
better at preparing for them and knowing
what to do when they strike
that means improving our Warning Systems
building stronger infrastructure and
educating people on how to stay safe
during a disaster
it's exciting to think about what the
future holds for natural disaster
control
and speaking of the future what if we
could settle on Mars
what challenges would we face and how
could life on the red planet change our
future that's a story for another
what if
[Music]